les événements continuent d'évoluer
après la tragédie de cet après midi au
sud-liban j'aurai dans quelques instants
direct de tel-aviv le ministre des
affaires étrangères français monsieur
hervé de charette des reportages et
d'autres invités qui viendront ici est
témoigné je voudrais rappeler le dernier
bilan d'att 94 tu es donc cet après midi
des civils libanais 105 blessés qui ont
été bombardés par l'armée israélienne
dans un quartier général des nations
unies où il avait trouvé refuge rappelle
d'abord des événements donc de cet
après-midi le l'enchaînement terribles
de ces événements avec patrice en deuil
dès l'entrée dans le baraquement l'odeur
de s'en prend à la gorge dit un rescapé
civière couvertures sacs en plastique
tout est bon pour évacuer les corps ou
ce qu'il en reste tout est bon pour
soustraire le carnage au regard des
mères
passée la stupeur les plus endurcis
casques bleus ou volontaire s'affairent
quant aux autres ils se croyaient à
l'abri au qg du bataillon fidjien de la
finul
une salve de cinq obus les a fauchés
c'est sans doute le hesbollah posté à
300 mètres de là qui étaient visés dans
les hôpitaux de la région ont submergé
de blessés
mêmes scènes d'effervescence même visage
tuméfié le massacre de cana a fait 100
morts et autant de blessés des civils